there's this right-wing stereotype or
talking point that many immigrants but
in particular refugees to the United
States fail to integrate into American
society there's the stereotype that we
don't want them because they'll always
uh be separate they'll never be part of
our culture's or our customs or speak
our language we actually have a new
report now on refugee integration and
looked at four groups uh Somali Burmese
Hmong and Bosnian refugees together
constituting about 500,000 US residents
and the reports looked at how do these
groups end up in terms of integration
and assimilation in the long run and the
report found much to the dismay of many
right-wing nativists and xenophobes that
refugees tend to integrate very well
into their new communities now you might
hear that and say David very well is an
objective measure how are you measuring
it well the report explains that for
example after being in the United States
for ten years refugees do just as well
to their us-born neighbors in terms of
work force participation in terms of
managerial positions and looking at
business ownership the overwhelming
majority of refugees have learned to
speak English which is often one of
those stereotypes they just don't learn
to speak English uh and many have become
naturalized US citizens after being in
the country for 20 years very important
findings here labor force participation
rates for refugee men specifically often
exceed those for us born men very
interesting Louis yeah that is quite
interesting but what about more social
things you know that would be my
question well those are harder to
measure I mean what's an example if you
speaking the language is sort of the key
one right i mean it's sort of like the
lowest common denominator for being
integrated into society if your question
is are they playing in pickup coed
soccer leagues after work to the same
degree that your average 30-year old is
I don't know I don't have the answer the
study didn't look at that but certainly
language is one of the most
lowest common denominators for
integration and something that the Trump
supporters and the haters always point
to they don't even learn the language
you need to learn English you need to
speak American uh but something they say
not something I say and of course we've
talked many times about the false notion
that immigrants and refugees are a
hindrance to the American economy and
we've also actually talked about
positive economic impact of undocumented
immigrants who in many cases are paying
into social welfare programs that they
will never actually receive benefits
from I won't go completely back into
that we have a long piece about that the
truth about undocumented immigration you
can find it on YouTube excellent
excellent piece researched and produced
by our segment producer Noah Ferguson
but needless to say yet another one of
these xenophobic nativists right-wing
talking points falls apart upon upon
just a pretty pretty basic inspection of
the claims